you know cuz I think about saying a lot
he's coming to you cuz Santa can sleep
through anything
you know he got a million on little
people you know her sonís
Becca Neos ham Renan is in his garage
another building trains they're building
walkie-talkies it's that time you know
suddenly the place where they were
making wagons suddenly back behind that
little building they got a little cook
house you know they grilling up brisket
and uh you know uppers methamphetamines
you know and so you know that Santa
right now he's got work to do
nobody works as hard as Santa think
about it Jesus maybe you know Mohammed
who's a little fat guy with the jewelry
on no I know some of you guys are
thinking probably of hit bull no I'm
talking about the Indian the day of the
Buddha so yeah you know his Santa is in
a class of his own but yeah dude every
you know things are getting softer dude
always thinking about this a lot of
c-section babies they should tell you if
somebody's a c-section baby or if they
went through the canal you know if
there's a real Andy Dufresne you feel me
I said I would take a man 600 years so
yeah this here prison but I need oof
rain hitting in less than nine months
because do premature babies they get
[ __ ] out the gig they cut out they
get a little you know they get the red
carpet somebody reaches in there and get
you I had the [ __ ] tighten my head up
into the shape of a vagina and squeeze
myself out into the world and you got
these little pre not premature as man am
i bad
you got these little whatever they you
know c-section baby ters yeah basically
the New England Patriots of humans
running around and they should put it
right on your neck CS or NB baby them
natural birth is breath that vag route
son
I remember getting on the plane and
eating the edible and it was me like
Martin and Gabriel and we were sitting
across from tree like old women and also
he had a post
hit me right mm-hmm I'm 380 I'm [ __ ]
huge
really it must be miserable I had to be
380 this is like 10 years ago I'm gonna
forget taking my shirt off and the sweat
was pouring down me and these little old
ladies were just looking at the floor
and there I am watching sweat another
time I went to delve into the hella book
like I'm so hungry the pack a set of
inserts that's a mistake called cinnamon
makes you sweat like a [ __ ]
healing dog I started sweating on the
plane there was a little gay guy next to
me and he was asleep ok people those
little things on their eyes I had to
take my shirt off there I am in first
class with the blanket up to my stomach
my tits are out
yeah you could feel the beat I remember
getting off the plane in Miami next
morning my pants were [ __ ] wet and to
store this we're just walking the halls
look at me and give me a water
she's a how [ __ ] up I was I've been to
jail I've been in jail yeah I like
blacked in mm-hmm
when cop lights were coming down the
street I was walking down the street in
the elf costume with my other friends
yeah all of a sudden my friend takes off
so I just start running and I jump a
fence and I land on the other side of
the fence and I just hear freeze and
they made me come back over the fence
finds my fake ID and they basically just
brought me to jail for being drunk
underage damn housing cellmates is a
warning yeah I had to did you
and they're both covered head-to-toe no
tattoos Oh in year if there's a let's
play somebody's getting [ __ ] in here
yeah I was wearing tights it's you yeah
you know I woke up in an elf costume
with tights on I don't know unaware I
might just always sees two guys with
face tattoos
oh yeah Stan and I literally stood up in
the first thing I said
shiny show pitch this is the time of
year where you can reimagine yourself
you know life is just still going
forward but suddenly somebody walks up
with a piece of chalk and they just draw
like a line in front of you and
sometimes a line is so powerful because
it can be a starting point it can be an
ending point it can connect to things I
got
how do I get from here to here oh I know
how alive you know a line is such a
simple thing and it can be so powerful
so this is that time of year where you
can set your line what do you want to
reel in do you want anything different
you just want to keep riding the same
you want to walk that tightrope and we
can do it and that's one thing is
beautiful about this time of year is
it's just a chance to kind of read yes
you know you could turn the gas off for
a little bit and now you can restart you
know whatever happened happened and now
I'm gonna I'm gonna put this line right
here and when I walk over the line I'm
gonna try something different I'm gonna
try to have a new experience for myself
we just got to take our brains in in
four direction and some of that
direction is movement movement will get
you going
the problem being in a urinal you
stalled out they don't have these
running urinals where you can run and
piss at the same time I could do that
right I like oh you run running run with
a spear MA on my hand jump off a cliff
piss at the same time how's that not an
Olympic sport dude we got this [ __ ] ass
type people jumping over hurdles who
gives a [ __ ] dude do something that's
really an Olympian could do I don't see
somebody jumping over hurdles and that's
not even an Olympian anymore that's just
a night that's an advertisement for a
company now I want to see that real
hitter I want to see somebody you know
you know catching a violent sheep or
something and strangling that thing you
know at the same time that he's aw
off of a third-story burning building
over there outside of Toledo
now we're talking that's the [ __ ]
Olympics get this other [ __ ] out of here
dude these days I think Santa could
probably catch some charges a big white
dude rolls down a chimney somewhere brah
then what are you doing here no it's not
gonna work super well right now I need
you to sit down you know probably a lot
of surprised a lot of extreme liberal
people they're probably gonna put little
caps on their chimneys I heard somebody
the other day a parent out here in Los
Angeles saying that they didn't want
their children celebrating Christmas
that it feels errant that gifts just
come out of nowhere and it creates a bad
example for their kids man [ __ ] that
this is Christmas man they said it's
scary the lady said the other day it's
scary to have them for your children
will imagine a man they don't know
coming down the tree [ __ ] that ain't a
man the Santa have we lost it this [ __ ]
man merry Christmas to everybody out
there who's celebrating that's what I'm
telling you yes suddenly it's like we're
doing so badly yeah man I love how
suddenly it's happened like all of a
sudden everything is horrible and really
when you get out into the world most
things are fine I'm noticing especially
in America it's a lot of the media's
just saying that things are bad things
you go outside it's not that way that
people are generally being pretty decent
to each other I think part of what's
happening is that as the traditional
media dies they get desperate for
attention they get all clickbait teased
yeah they exaggerate the polarization
and the catastrophe the best example of
that is there's way more coverage of
violent crime than there was 25 years
ago
hmm but there's half as much violent
crime like in the five major measures of
violent crime have fallen by 50% in the
last 25 years like who knows that no one
like no we're not it's safe for now in
the United States then it's ever been
it's safer now than it was in the early
60s you've never guessed that think
about it that specifically dangerous
things carefully that's such a place
where kids learn oh yeah that is the
only place they learned that's where
everyone learns everything when you're
doing dangerous things carefully man
that's where you learn when you see your
three-year-old daughter climbing up the
monkey bars our daughter used to do that
in our backyard you know and she
three in the monkey bars were cold eight
feet high she liked to go right to the
top and climb across them it's like
we're watching out the back window
thinking but what do you do we you want
around there be careful there's a bit of
malevolence in that oh my daughter is
worrying me I'll go out there and take
care of her about startled er then
she'll fall well that'll fix her she
won't do that again
she won't make me nervous it's like you
gotta watch those things man right it's
not about them it's about you yes that's
for sure that's what you got to ask
yourself am i taking care of my child or
am I just afraid to be afraid for them
mmm-hmm did you enjoy that clip well you
really would have enjoyed it if he was
watching on a TCL TV TCL is America's
fastest growing TV brand it's so fast
it's the Carl Lewis of television brands
it's that Florence Griffith visual
jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com